well how about how about we talk about
those falsehoods we got this report from
newsweek half of joe biden's twitter
followers are fake reviews
what's this information
i believe this people are going you're
telling me he got 80 million followers
i believe this was true also we were
looking at this today at post millennial
uh i think this was also true of justin
trudeau's twitter followers most of them
are what is this based off of just so
well there's an audit company it's
called uh spark tour so it's based on
dinesh's documentary because i'm really
cynical about this stuff only because i
know when you sign up to twitter you're
gonna get like three people it's gonna
be like joe biden
elon musk and like jack or something and
like so i'd understand
why so i'd like to look at i don't know
i'd like to understand the methodology a
little bit what's going on i don't know
if they reveal their methodology and i
think they said uh fake or spam accounts
and it's uh i'm sorry that was musk that
was musk well i guess they said there
was like this tweet harvesting it's not
clear how musk arrived at the twenty
percent figure he figured al gore and
changed a series of tweets anyway
so there's a couple ways to do it i
think elon may have made a mistake when
agrawal said it was less than five
percent he said of daily active users
of their active users the fake accounts
comprise of less than five percent
elon musk based on this said all users
must be around 20 so there's a
difference there are a lot of users that
don't do anything they're counting
monthly or daily active users or
whatever but
i believe this is uh um likely true
because the potus account whenever a bot
or a spam bot
will sign up it's going to follow
prominent accounts to try and look real
and of course it's going to follow the
president so that it's like following a
bunch of verified accounts and here's a
big one well isn't it funny how like
it's a bunch of accounts
with people who we know are not the
actual person following an account that
we know is not being tweeted by the
actual person either
it's like joel is not running the
twitter account the whole thing is fake
joe biden's not running the twitter
account he's not running the country
believe it yeah exactly
well elon musk says whoever's
controlling the teleprompter but yeah
donald trump actually was tweeting one
of there is no denying was actually
trading he could not hire a writer to
write those things he was tweeting from
the bathroom donald trump as president
everybody tweets he would watch can you
imagine someone being like i was donald
trump's tweet writer like putting that
on your resume no it was trump there's
no way anyone else said anything would
you imagine a staffer's outside the
bathroom reading a tweet just being like
he would watch fox news and then he
would tweet it right away
and he'd be like tucker said this or did
you hear about this then he would go to
rallies and he'd repeat it it was really
obvious that he would just watch fox and
be like boom something happened i i kind
of i liked it i mean oh yeah
you know and and you know being a
journalist and
seeing
trump just tweet random things was
really a lot of fun you could get like a
whole bunch of stories just
i was saying on twitter i was told by
people
it was violence
that every every day they had they were
there were people journalists who were
assigned
to
like there were journalists at news
organizations who were told your job is
to keep refreshing trump's twitter feed
and then when he says something write it
up oh my god and they were saying it was
violence his tweets they were saying
that it was like stressful and that they
needed like you know health days
that once once he lost the election
they're like finally it's over i'm sorry
once he got banned they were like like
i'm crying to give joy like i can go
back to normal working now no more
stress
they were saying how they would get text
messages at two in the morning from
their boss being like trump just tweeted
write it up and they'd be like uh
no the world's surrounding these guys
really it's really not that bad like i
work from home i live in new york city i
have a job as a journalist sometimes i
have to write things at 2 a.m and it's
like it's totally fine i have no problem
doing that
as we saw
the twitter leaks from veritas
this guy said he worked what four hours
in the last quarter yeah that's right he
did their children they don't want to
work the craziest thing is i saw someone
post something where they were like
uh
they said something about
all of my friends who are going on
vacation their summer plans and you know
i'm stuck here with the kids and i'm and
i'm just like i don't understand if he's
i don't know if he's complaining or if
he's like
bragging i don't know what he's trying
to say but the conversation was
basically like the uh the dinks the dual
income no kids people were like going to
travel and partying living the good life
and it's like
i don't you know what i don't get i'll
i'll i'll segue sort of
why everybody wants to be younger i
don't get that either
it's like you i mean i don't want to be
older either but i don't want to be
younger well i don't care either way
it's like you live you grow you age and
then aging yes i think aging is going to
be painful i'm not really quite looking
forward to that ah we're all like look
a lot better than the alternative yes
a lot of really great people who came
before us
got old yeah and they died and i'm just
like why would i not want the human
experience yeah that is part of wait
that sounds like a cope i i'd want to
live longer if i could
i could almost live forever yeah because
it almost sounds like you you say you
don't want to live forever because we
don't have the opportunity to and i'm
saying that to make myself feel better
you know what's funny is i have this
same debate with my son who is 12 and we
talk about whether or not you'd want to
live forever and i'm always like yeah
you'd want to live forever that's
amazing you know you could see
everything you could see how the the
human story comes to a final conclusion
like what really happens and he's like
yeah but you'd have to watch all the
people that you love and care about die
why would you want to do that mom yeah
but that's that's not the issue the
issue is after you know a good 30 years
you're like i understand humans
yeah i i don't think there's any you
know i mean maybe maybe you'll watch i
don't want to live forever maybe you'll
watch technology develop and then you'll
get to the point where you can plug your
brain in the matrix or something but i'm
just like i would i would rather in the
human experience is the human experience
i don't understand why it's a bad thing
that no people not a bad thing i mean
it's just well i don't understand why
it's something to be avoided i don't
think i actually appointed either person
i looked forward to being old
but if if like were the opportunities to
live further no that would be cool did
you ever see that i'd like to live to be
like 150 something like that remember
when johnny knoxville dressed up like an
old man and just caused trouble
it's because people are like he's an old
guy what are you going to do about it
you know are you saying that's going to
be you as an old man like grandpa
simpson yeah not grandpa simpson like
johnny knoxville was doing like he would
walk in he would just like grab a bunch
of groceries and just like walk away but
they're like he's just an old guy he's
confused i don't know what grandpa
simpson does he says that they let you
shoplift oh okay okay well there you go
well i wouldn't shoplift but you know
when you're old it's just like you just
go and do it's like it's like
you've got nothing left to lose the
world's your oyster you know go
skydiving and you're like when you're
like 90. yes you want to do that heart
attack you could run for president why
go skydiving you could still be
president i think bernie sanders is
about to run again do you think he's
gonna run yeah i do i think i think
donald trump was probably thinking that
he was talking about like kids and stuff
i i look forward to the summer because
because i have to travel a lot for work
and i'm looking forward to the summer
because i'm gonna take my son with me to
all of the places that i have to go and
i'm stoked it's gonna be awesome that
sounds beautiful right we're gonna like
i'm really hoping i can find good hotels
with nice pools this is what i'm this is
what i'm hoping for for my summer how do
we get into immortality from bots on
twitter well because because robots
never die
yeah those bots are going to carry joe
biden's wisdom in the future
the person running joe biden's account
is actually a bot
elon doesn't audit okay that would not
be surprising
the person standing at the podium is
actually a bot if you look at the
ridiculous things that his account
tweets out it does so i i read it would
be really funny if just like one day
when joe was like stuttering a guy
walked up with like a screwdriver and
like bopped him on the arm and then like
jiggled him and then he was like oh
the economy has been in dire strait for
some time it's like no he would never
admit that percussive mate of
maintenance is i think they call it
no like he's malfunctioning sparks are
coming up
yeah well biden thinks putin is running
the country and that's why everything's
going to hell well i saw a conspiracy uh
pyramid a while ago tim and i believe it
had biden as a robot as one of the
conspiracy theories yeah actually let me
double check let me tell let me double
check it as bio as a robot that's that
that's like conspiracy theories are
usually negative right it's like a bad
thing is happening if body was a robot
oh that's a good that's pretty good you
know because like right now it wouldn't
be such a bad robot he's not a bad robot
i'm worried about biden's capabilities
to do the job and it turns out he's
actually a robot i'd be like oh okay you
know
you know biden's in in poor health but
robots all right i think we should be
concerned about biden's ability to run
the country oh one million percent we i
mean i we should have been concerned
during the primaries we were we were
it's really terrifying to see someone
who is uh as dotty and confused as this
old man is
actually try to lead the entire world
essentially isn't it which is the job i
mean the fact that the democratic party
even picked him like they had other
options they had other options
i don't know why they don't like if the
idea was that anyone could beat trump
why not run booty judge right
there's like no we have him now anyway
he's out there fixing potholes what do
you think about elon he tweeted that
he's uh officially running as a
republican i'm sorry he's officially
voting yeah calm down
we need a disinformation board right now
hold on by the way i have to say so i
pulled the conspiracy theory pyramid up
again yes biden is a robot is a
conspiracy theory on there not only that
but it is a theater that it is a theory
that makes you a danger to yourself and
others to believe thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you